[Music]
so recently
this girl she's a former love and
hip-hop hollywood
star named masika she
posted a video of herself in lingerie
with apparent cuts and scrapes and
bruises all over her body
claiming that she got kidnapped and that
she was still in danger and in order for
her to to not be in danger anymore
people needed to go follow her only fans
and tip her dude i was thinking that as
a joke
and it [ __ ] you said it true yeah wow
all right so i'm gonna play this clip
and i just want to warn you guys
that it might be triggering for
because it portrays like i said you know
she has like scrapes and bruises all
over her body
and she's like shaking so this might be
to release me
please join my only fans was she trying
to say it as if it was real or is it yes
part of the theme stupid
here we go ready enough oh my god
is that tick-tock
i don't know no it's like a voice
recorder i mean um
it says play with the monkeys yes it
looks funny
they said that you guys have to leave me
tips and follow me
so they can take them in here they're
not gonna let me
it's so stupid
oh my god please help
tip me 100.
because now we know but imagine seeing
this and not knowing it wasn't real
it people got hella triggered how
desperate is she okay so here
you need to kid me and she shows her ass
up
you need a tip they're gonna [ __ ] do
it
she was showing the bruises but it's
like a it's like
this weird thirst trap yeah but let me
also manipulate these people that is so
[ __ ] up on so many levels exactly so
uh shortly after she posted that video
she deleted the video
and then she posted this video
hey guys um now that i got your
attention i wanted to talk about
something very important
um i'm sorry if i scared you but
sometimes you need that shock factor
um i'm on set right now filming for my
new show and this is all
camera makeup i'm totally fine guys but
um the show that i am
on right now is about child sex
trafficking what
and um this is a very challenging role
for me um because shooting this
show i've done a lot of research and
i've had to dig deep i have to make it
short because i gotta go on set but i've
joined forces with the rose organization
i need you guys to follow them to
women that have been in sex trafficking
i meant well so i hope
i hope no one was checking out uh but
that's messed up [ __ ] that's messed
up
that's her cover-up it is a cover-up
dude after she [ __ ]
got all this flagport shoes like holy
[ __ ] i gotta [ __ ] do something
for this oh by the way i did this for
charity i did this to [ __ ] spread
awareness you know
i mean hopefully since she name dropped
an organization hopefully she actually
is working with somebody
oh guess what i'm on set right now so
name dropping these things dude this is
[ __ ] funny
call her out this is [ __ ] hilarious
or you can go on her imdb too is she
really on
is there a pre-production for this show
that she's on about child sex
um i didn't look into that but going to
about the organization that she
mentioned
she mentioned the rose organization and
the founder of this
organization i don't know who the [ __ ]
she is posted this
i've seen something that came across
this morning but late last night
um in reference to masika doing a scene
or something
saying that it was for my organization
and you know i thank her for my for for
the support
but i did not approve of that video
i will not and my organization will not
be receiving money or accepting
donations
from online fans or fans daily or
whatever it's called
that video it triggered a lot of people
i had a lot of people in my dms i had a
lot of people
you know asking me questions about it um
[ __ ] she actually triggered me a little
bit i had to
get my mind right and get myself
together but no in no way shape or form
is meseka the spokesperson for rose
rose is my organization
yeah dude this is [ __ ] stupid on
level 100. but then she got interviewed
by tmz which i don't have that video
like it's interviewed by tmz and she
just doubled down on it she was like
she was saying like it it accomplished
what she was trying to accomplish which
was to get
eyeballs on this organization oh my god
very passionate about
and that's not the way she's hilarious
because then she said
she was like if everyone like there's
triggers everywhere
right so she was like you can't go to
the grocery store or the gas station or
anywhere
because there's triggers everywhere so i
apologize that i offended
or triggered something she's like dawg
look at this pc culture not letting me
pretend to be sex trafficked
and get your money and tell you to go to
my only that's serious
she tried to do a quick stunt to make
[ __ ] money
it backfired so she tried to cover her
tracks that's what happened
i don't know why with another [ __ ]
these people
fake ass apology video these people keep
dropping names of
other people who can say that they're
lying true why don't they just say
i'm making a movie independent not
working with anyone
yeah what fun
yeah she has 2.4 million followers on
instagram
she on her bio it's like musician
actress activist writer
entrepreneur she also has like other
businesses
and stuff so liar she's saying i didn't
need this money
i just wanted to bring awareness
and to give the money to the
organization but as far as i know she
hasn't commented on
the founder commenting on not accepting
the money so i don't know
what's going to happen with that damn
interesting right
that's so crazy it's messed up i feel
like if
if it is um you tell people it's a
dramatization or something
like that obviously that can still bring
awareness
for something that is as triggering if
you're trying to do
something like that to bring awareness
like there's this one video i've been
seeing
on ticktark or instagram where during a
facetime this girl puts like a
she does a sign or something it's like
i'm doing well and she does assign to
the other girl
on the other side of the facetime
signaling that she is stuck in like a
domestic abusive
oh yeah i think i've seen this
relationship right you know it seems
very real um like the way that it shot
and everything so people when people
were uploading it and being like
holy crap this girl's in trouble or
whatever but it was meant to be like
some kind of a commercial
you know what i mean some kind of
awareness but they didn't put that out
there like it's an ad
yeah yeah like maybe people were cutting
out the the context you know what i mean
but this is a blatant you know like
wrongful use i lied but
and she was lying and it's just yeah
it's
yeah not good it is not good so she is
obviously getting
crazy backlash you're good joe yeah how
many unfollowers she got man that is
effed she probably got more followers
maybe yeah it's a sick world
it's a sick world it sure works weird oh
my god
you're crying joe dude this is probably
one of the funniest things i've seen in
a long [ __ ] time dude
it's so [ __ ] stupid share the comic
mind why is it so funny that you're
crying
okay so first all right you can you
can you understand her thought process
like we all see it right
she thinks she's fooling the [ __ ]
world dude she thinks she's pulling a
fast one on us
like think about it in her own head she
thinks that she's still getting away
with this
but everyone else is kind of like we see
your [ __ ] dude
all right and she keeps going on tmz and
she's doubling down he's delirious
think about the mind that it takes to
believe
that they can pull off this stunt and
it's gonna be amazing
like and not just that but not even
consult
the organization that you are promoting
like hey is this cool with you i have
this idea even if
like how insanely well she probably
googled it
so she first hired she had a stupid ass
idea
that you have to hire a makeup artist to
do the the
original damages right like she's really
working on a production no i don't know
she's just obviously this
and then uh right after she's like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] backfired so i
don't know if you noticed but from the
second video to the first idiot
video all of a sudden she has a black
eye so i think she's like okay i gotta
double down even on the injuries
i gotta make my injuries look like i'm
really on set so she just randomly has a
black eye now
and so she had to tell the makeup artist
to probably either come back again
or it was right then and there and she
had to do all of that and it's just
yeah it's just ridiculous she probably
saw the backlash and said
oh [ __ ] google the [ __ ] org exactly
and she was like she did have a black
guy in the first one i just double
checked oh
it was just really grainy hard to see
it's just [ __ ] up to anyone who is
really in a situation similar to that
obviously it is we i mean i'm sure we're
all on the same page as that but
yeah the way she did it is wow
right it's just so cringe it's like why
would you do that
no idiot man i respect her
courage and the balls that she had to
to keep running with her lie and double
down on him like this
i don't respect that you think when she
was planning she was telling all her
friends
i have a great idea i'm gonna do this
[ __ ] and
fake out people from my only fans and
you think her friends were like yeah
probably some people kick it with dumb
people
yeah she's probably running a lot of
like yes
i did this because you need to know that
there's
people out there that we all i'm
i don't care if you hate on me and you
talk all this [ __ ] because
it worked and now the whole world knows
rose
the whole world knows about sex
trafficking and i spread that awareness
i was the one go to this organization
yeah
subscribe to my only fans i'm looking at
her at her imdb
and yeah i don't see anything any kind
of project that
is cause they tell you about future
projects too yeah
[ __ ] dude i can't believe
because you could have done that that
initial stunt video
without the uh telling people to tip her
a hundred dollars yeah
you know that's why that was actually a
specific amount
all the call to actions too she's like
go to my only fans and make sure to sip
on here
[Laughter]
that's how they're going to release me
so you have to tip me a hundred dollars
and that maybe then they'll release i
love how it's not
call the [ __ ] cops it's subscribe to
my only fans
i need it you see this bruise and then
she has her ass shot
it's kind of like come on dude she had
to show it the other way around yeah
was yeah the bruise was here and she
could have went like this
but she was like to show you the bruise
[Laughter]
to make them want to subscribe dude
yeah man and then people are just like
dude like
even in your explanation like you
couldn't even address how [ __ ]
insensitive it was
or how you triggered so many people yeah
she did say sorry i scared you
there's a method to my madness but a lot
of people are really upset
sorry you're sensitive yeah i'm sorry
that you're sensitive and you got
offended for my actions yeah she even
talked about [ __ ] pc culture
basically that
you can't you can't go anywhere without
getting offended these days you could go
to whole foods and get
offended that's what she was saying yeah
that's doubling down on it come
on when did that happen by the way oh
this is recent
yeah twitter august 25th
is wow is from one of the screenshots
[Music]
you